bye
when mankind is consumed by darkness and
the land falls into chaos
the archdemon of the abyss shall rise
from the earth
they come rushing here in a desperate
attempt to survive
both beasts and man have more in common
than they think
brace yourself
[Music]
[Music]
and these wandering flags
shall feed the beast
and return to darkness
a story ends
another begins
[Music]
wandering flames
[Music]
i see you found your home
[Music]
remember what you're fighting for
[Music]
this
is let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hello everyone welcome to today's
nintendo direct mini partner showcase
in this presentation we'll be focusing
on nintendo switch games launching this
year from our publishing and development
partners
okay let's get into the headlines
the battle to reclaim earth begins
the year is 5012 a.d
machine life forms have overwhelmed the
planet causing the collapse of
civilization and forcing humans to take
refuge on the moon
now with an android squad called yorha
the humans are prepared to stand against
these machine life form invaders
[Music]
a battle android 2b
and a scanner android 9s
are two key members of this squad
machine lifeforms in conflict with
androids
what will come of this bloodless battle
[Music]
you just
die already
this version of the award-winning nier
automata comes with previously released
content including additional modes and
costumes
new costumes exclusive to the nintendo
switch version will also be available at
launch
reclaim earth in near automata the end
of jorah edition launching on the
nintendo switch system october 6th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
[Music]
get ready to immerse yourself in surreal
riddles and a chilling story in this
modern take on puzzle adventure games
[Music]
solve the enigma of lorelei and the
laser eyes launching first for consoles
on nintendo switch next year
[Music]
familiar faces are making a splash in
these games
a new bomberman game is coming to
nintendo switch this time a bombastic
new mode called castle mode enters the
fray a team of up to 15 players must
blast their way to treasure chests while
one defending player tries to hold them
off set up your defense wisely to blow
away opponents literally you can also
create and share your own battle stages
have a blast when super bomberman r2
launches on nintendo switch next year
[Music]
10 mega man battle network games
originally released on the game boy
advance system are coming to nintendo
switch control mega man in grid-based
combat and use battle chips to gain
devastating abilities
this collection includes a gallery with
over 1 000 illustrations and a music
mode containing over 150 songs from
across the series
mega man battle network legacy
collection launches on nintendo switch
next year the full collection will also
be digitally available as volume 1 and
volume 2 each sold separately
a remake of pacman world is coming soon
pac-man's family has been kidnapped to
rescue them he sets off for ghost island
eating dots isn't all you can do here
trounce enemies with pack dots the rev
roll the butt bounce and
a giant pacman from high-speed chases to
galactic escapades you'll explore all
sorts of zany levels save the pack fan
in pac-man world repack launching a
nintendo switch august 26th
two unlikely friends
one incredible journey
a fawn and a wolf cub must work together
to find a way home across the snowy
wilderness in the handcrafted world of
blanc
in this emotional adventure
these unlikely friends must coordinate
and use their individual strengths to
solve environmental puzzles and navigate
through the frigid wilds
blanc is a completely text-free story
with local and online co-op play so all
players can enjoy it
forge an unexpected bond in blanc
launching as a console exclusive on
nintendo switch february 2023
[Music]
a swashbuckling adventure returns
[Music]
pirating is in my blood
like adrenaline or stale grog
i've been in enough scraps to fill a
dozen scrapbooks
i've got stories about ships fights love
treasure betrayal and root beer but how
about one that has all of the above
my name is guybrush three board and this
is a story about the time
i finally found the secret of monkey
island
[Music]
guy brush three wood
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
monkey around in return to monkey island
launching first for consoles on nintendo
switch this year
next we have some news about a game that
was announced last june
please take a look
mario and the rabbids blast off for a
galactic adventure in the latest mario
plus rabbids game
space is in a universe of trouble when
other worldly enemies suddenly appear
their goal
take the energy possessed by sparks
these mysterious creatures
now our heroes must set out to save them
a new adventure of epic proportions
awaits
[Music]
you'll initiate a turn-based battle when
you encounter an enemy
[Music]
before we begin here's something you
ought to know
you can freely move around the
battlefield as much as you'd like within
your character's range before using
their weapon pretty neat huh
let's start with mario
three enemies are in the way so let's
dash into one of them
now select rabid rosalina and have her
dash into another
next rabbit luigi
one more dash and now disrupter time
by using a dash first then the weapon
three enemies were wiped out with that
his turn is over
back to mario
let's take out the other two pew pew
that concludes his turn
last but not least rabid rosalina team
up with an ally and jump
get positioned then finish off with the
kaboomer
okay our turn's over
and now the enemy attacks be sure to
take cover and you might be safe
if you don't it won't be pretty
all right we've got the floor again
[Music]
dash toward the bomb
and if you chuck it over
boom
that'll do it
the key to victory is how you assemble
your team and navigate around the
battlefield
wait is that bowser and he's joining the
team
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
rockets onto the nintendo switch system
october 20th pre-orders begin today on
nintendo eshop
check out ubisoft's special showcase
tomorrow for more details about mario
plus rabbids sparks of hope
[Music]
we hope you're looking forward to the
chaotic adventures of mario and the
rabbits
let's take a look at more headlines
there's something for everyone on
nintendo switch
during a storm young alchemist noah
crash lands in ancient ruins
the layout of these multi-layered ruins
changes every time you enter them
recruit allies called lilliputs to
challenge the enemies lurking around
every corner
string together combos and perform
powerful elemental attacks to defeat
foes
little noah scion of paradise launches a
nintendo switch later today
[Music]
all aboard
in the management sim braille grade
you'll build railway systems to
efficiently transport cargo and help
restore economic prosperity to an
industrial colony
complete various tasks to prepare each
shipment before it's delivered to its
destination your strategies will change
based on various factors like the number
and length of trains to run
which resources to acquire
and how to transport cargo from point a
to point b
railgrade steamrolls onto nintendo's
witch this fall
join aspiring game creator kenta in a
hand-drawn adventure to save the world
in his latest creation the legend of
right
taking place in kenta's notebook this
rpg spans over 200 pages where you must
draw
erase
solve puzzles and even consult your
handy calculator
discover a new way to play every time
you turn the page
rpg time the legend of right unfolds
onto nintendo switch august 18th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
spin dash into a new zone
sonic's latest action adventure kicks
off on the vibrant star fall islands
home to a mysterious civilization
here you can freely dash through a vast
open zone taking full advantage of
sonic's speedy skills
[Music]
lock on and attack enemies standing in
your way
chain together attacks to trigger combos
and rack up damage
with good timing you can even deflect
enemy attacks
acquire skills to bolster sonic's
arsenal of moves
you can also enter a special zone called
cyberspace
take on challenges at supersonic speeds
and grab keys to progress
what awaits sonic on these strange
islands
sonic frontiers dashes onto nintendo
switch this holiday
live magically alongside your disney and
pixar friends
dream life valley was once an idyllic
land where disney and pixar characters
lived in harmony until the forgetting
turned this dream into a nightmare
now it's up to you to help these iconic
residents recover their lost memories
and reveal the secrets that led you here
bring the magic back to dreamlight
valley in this mesmerizing life
simulation adventure explore this land's
many diverse realms and forge lasting
friendships with heroes and villains
alike
everyone you meet will have personal
stories to discover and adventures to
complete help them out by exploring
giving them gifts and performing other
fun activities
in this world you can be whoever you
dream yourself to be
dreamlight valley launches on nintendo
switch september 6th as an early access
title
take these adventures with you on the go
live alive is coming alive on july 22nd
multiple stories featuring different
protagonists time periods and gameplay
await now in hd 2d
[Music]
a demo with the start of three chapters
imperial china twilight of edo japan
and the distant future will be available
on nintendo eshop later today
save data from the demo can be
transferred to the full game once
purchased
duraimon nobi and their friends land on
an unknown planet and decide to help a
new friend fulfill his dreams by farming
plow the fields harvest crops
and tend to the animals
you can even use duraimon's secret
gadgets to farm in a flash
relax by living with friends
eating delicious meals
and fishing
and with local play you and a pal can
build a ranch together
deraimon story of seasons friends of the
great kingdom launches on the nintendo
switch system this year
the world of minecraft meets action
strategy gameplay in minecraft legends
a beautiful land surrounded by rich
nature is invaded by enemies from
another dimension
team up with allies and fight against
this monstrous force threatening the
world what secrets await in this new yet
familiar universe
minecraft legends launches on nintendo
switch next year
it's a treasure hunter's paradise
two siblings dream of collecting grand
treasures from around the world
venture to the realm of draconia to
become legendary treasure hunters in
this dragon quest series spin-off you'll
recruit a variety of well-mannered
monsters to join you on a marvelous
adventure
with their help and with your trusty
fortune finder locating loot will be a
breeze
monsters are perfect travel buddies for
exploring this vast world
bounce on a slime to reach high ledges
or dangle from a dracky to glide over
gaping chasms
support your monsters in battle as they
fearlessly fend off foes
bring your hard-earned hull back to your
base and see how much it's worth
collect more riches to expand your base
and increase your treasure hunting level
x marks the spot when dragon quest
treasures launches on nintendo switch
december 9th
[Music]
divorces
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to have so much fun together
at first
your participation is appreciated and
required
there might even be cake
the portal companion collection will be
available later today
i wanted to call it the why do you keep
killing me collection
but oh well
let's get started you monster
[Music]
farm fight
and forge friendships in a new fantasy
world
welcome to leafy a peaceful village
where seasons brightly color the
environment
your story begins here in this brand new
life simulation rpg
do a little farm work
cook and craft items
[Music]
and trek through the fields to collect
materials
all while meeting townsfolk along the
way
the seasons gently flow from spring
summer fall and winter
however
they will give way to the season of
death
quietus
crops wither
life is threatened
[Music]
find a way to stop the season of death
from wreaking havoc on your home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fate of the village depends on you
begin your new life in harvestella
launching a nintendo switch november 4th
[Music]
this next segment will be our last
announcement please take a look
[Music]
mission
start
yeah
coming at ya
i'm morgana reigning ace of the phantom
thieves apart
and today i'm bringing along an ultra
top secret video
[Music]
i hope you're ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep persona 5 royal will launch nintendo
switch october 21st
and that's not all
let's keep the ball rolling huh teddy
[Music]
nice baton pass morgana
okay everyone check this out
[Music]
persona 4 golden and persona 3 portable
are also coming
[Music]
keep your eyes peeled for more persona
on nintendo switch
[Music]
that's all for today's nintendo direct
mini partner showcase thank you for
watching
[Music]
oh
you